[Music]
you are listening to a very special
quarantine edition of life assured
perhaps the most special yeah life could
be a dream sweetheart
well we'll have to see but so far it is
you know it's the tenth one oh so that's
special yeah nice round number oh can
you believe this has lasted ten weeks
you mean the show or the quarantine
um both
i guess i was psychologically preparing
for about this so yeah maybe
i think now it's starting to feel i'm
starting to really feel it exponentially
like in a way that i didn't before i'll
ask you that question again on episode
100. okay oh my god that's the next big
i guess i'll ask you again at 50.
quarantine episode number 15. when would
that be that would be a year from now
yeah
i mean it could be
we were talking about yeah it could be i
mean
we'll talk to dr dave in a second but uh
in terms of things going back to normal
normal like like uh they canceled chris
and i
we enjoy summering at tangowood there's
a place up in massachusetts called tango
woodward which is like an outdoor
amphitheater in the berkshires the
berkshires and the best thing to do is
to go watch john williams the boston
pops plays john williams music and oh my
god under the stars james taylor plays
there not at the same time uh but it's
it's just so such enjoyable moments of
life and
that sadly has been canceled this year
um
and i wonder when things like that are
gonna i mean
gatherings like that are gonna be
possible again i think it's gonna be a
while we just came back from the
berkshires and
we were with a couple friends james and
gemma shout out shorty shout out they're
shorties are they yeah i mean they
listen
uh i don't know if they're officially
shorties shorties is a very specific
thing yeah but it's a group on facebook
i know so it's so you can't be a shorty
unless you're part of that facebook
group i don't know
i would say unfair well why not just
join the facebook group well i don't
think see togo listen to every episode i
think he's a shorty oh really i think
he's an official shorty meaning he's
post he's i think he's on the facebook
okay i think well maybe james is too
uh i don't think so maybe anyway we were
there with them and gemma his wife is
a it reminded me of what you're saying
she's um a ballet choreographer former
ballet dancer and she was saying that
there's really no end in sight with
something like the ballet or
anything that requires
um you know
an audience yeah a live audience and in
something like ballet it's it's can't
really replicate that in a non
live generally zoom ballet very
effectively i know i've been wanting to
do a fundraiser for my friend barry
edelstein's theater uh one of my
favorite theaters the old globe in san
diego just a great beautiful space and
um i've had some so much fun doing plays
there myself but we've been wanting to
put together this charity thing we
thought maybe donald and i donald faison
and i could read do reading of the odd
couple or something so we're working on
something like that but and i've noticed
other friends
theater friends doing
benefits like that but there's something
about i mean the like you said the most
valuable component the most essential
component of any
theater is the audience whether it's
one or two people i know also i mean
broadway they say an amphitheater it
could be over a year before it comes
back also in with things like ballet and
theater the audiences tend to be older
so
obviously they're higher risk so i i
just don't see
audiences older audience specifically
crowding anytime soon but
hopefully there's some miracle drug
miracle cure so we're going to talk to
dr dave about that and about the fact
that speaking of gatherings and
uh people not doing them now shouldn't
be doing them
our grandmother our wily stubborn 103
year old grandmother we just found out
yesterday
her young upstart 95 year old friend
winnie took her to uh a restaurant
a restaurant crazy and and my mother was
like oh well they only have four tables
and they stayed away from people and
said but why she's not she's not and a
few days ago she went to get her hair
cut right because it was
she was like it's just out of control
i saw it it was well even if it was i
know you're 103. i know but i guess like
who's just
she has an afro she grows in africa easy
for me to say that it's she shouldn't
worry about it but if you're
if that's important to you and you want
to look presentable and i i mean who am
i to say he shouldn't do that but look
at us
yeah we look great although your hair
looks good you're but that's that was a
do it yourself it was a diy moment in
quarantine where uh you hate that
a diy yeah i don't love it
um where maggie did it your girlfriend
yeah i uh i got a haircut yeah you look
i'm a little overgrown yeah it is oh
speaking of being in the berkshires with
our friends this weekend memorial day
weekend
uh so beautiful so fun we got some frogs
we caught a lot of things oh my god they
were there with their they brought their
two-year-old reed because they don't
want to leave her home alone
they're very responsible they brought
their two-year-old daughter who is so
cute and curious and that's it was such
a fun age to see someone experiencing
nature and you know and she can she can
talk a little bit now and yeah she says
like just enough words i was trying to
figure out if her english is better than
my spanish
i think it might be slightly well i
think it is because when
james was like hey how do you say toes
in spanish you're like i have no idea
that said reedy's toes
and and
that's what i'm when i was wondering uh
if my spanish was better and
yeah i don't know how to say that but i
can form sentences better than she can
that's true i just don't know as many
words for things but she saw she met her
first frog that was a thrill for me he
kissed it
kissed it on the
it's a really funny video um that i
didn't want to put on my instagram
because you know it's not my kid not for
me to do uh
fortunately for the kid because i would
just plastered my kid all over instagram
but it was a really cute funny video
where she she actually kisses it um on
the
on the skin on the frog's mouth i
couldn't believe she did that yeah she
did it without without any encouragement
and then i caught uh briefly don't get
upset i threw it back right away i
caught a large mouth bass and um and i i
brought it up to her to kiss that and
she
that freaked her out understandably it's
a large mouth but it's like just
monstrous looking her mother gemma had
said she was like i think the only or
maybe james that pointed this out the
only fish she's really experienced are
from uh
dory finding nemo finding nemo the
sequel but she watches obsessively dory
and so just to go from like a cute
little like nemo fish like i don't know
where i'm going that doesn't sound like
ellen so when she meets a large amount
of bass she must be like why doesn't
this sound like ellen degeneres number
one why
something's off yeah and now when she
meets ellen that's the funny thing when
you do like a really iconic kid's voice
like kristen bell or whoever like josh
cat then i'm sure when kids meet them
they must be so confused why do you
sound like nemo
um
really fun we had a great time and then
met a snap found a little baby snapping
turtle a new all these all this wildlife
but yet to see her experience wildlife
is
really thrilled and now we want to
develop a tv show where you host a
nature show for kids oh my god dream job
it would be it's a layup that pitch is a
layup do you think
i think so yeah wow i'd love it uh we
also while we were up there uh in the in
the woods in nature
god all the sounds the night sounds
because now it's also there's a vernal
pond by our house which is which is just
a springtime pond uh rainwater collects
and then it disappears at some point in
the summer and all the frogs just frolic
there they go there in april and may and
just
[ __ ]
it's just constant it's just like a
rager it's like um
i imagine what fire island was at one
point
i mean
you know but with the same food only you
and only you would think of frogs as
frolicking well because you you like
them
you humanize them yeah i'm like oh
they're getting a lot of sex a lot of
sex is happening i can't imagine using
that term to describe well that's what
you hear at night you think about it
when all those beautiful night sounds
where they're like spring peepers and
you hear all the frogs at night it's
just a cacophony it's just like an
explosion of a symphony of frogs and
what they're doing is they're just horny
they're just like looking isn't that do
you ever think that like oh my god that
those sounds are just like ah what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] me let's [ __ ] let's [ __ ] uh
well thanks for i did no i did i don't
think that way i just enjoy the
tranquility of the sound but now from
now on i will be thinking
about like panicky horny screams like i
don't know how long i live
also this vernal pond this vernal pond
is gonna disappear soon we gotta get it
done also one more thing we should say
before we call dr dave yeah while up
there we got a delivery from a listener
of the show
it is a company called bob's pickle pops
and on instagram you look it up bob's
pickle pops that's what it is right yeah
bob's pickle yeah they reached out
on the dms they went down on the dm
and they sent us
uh their product a lot of their product
and we tried it the first night i tried
it basically their
what were those icy uh streets yeah
there were kids they came in like strips
they came in um and then you froze them
i think just icy pops right yeah they're
like juicy kind of like the way
string cheese comes in that form but
with juice inside that you freeze and
you just i think there's called ice pops
ice pops yeah so these are that makes
yeah ice bubs same shape as that same
setup only very different experience
very different experience because it's
made of pickle juice
how would you describe it initially the
first time it's you have to kind of
mentally prepare yourself well i messed
up the first time i tried it because we
were
uh
indulging
is that fair to say yeah we're indulging
and not completely clear-headed
and we had gotten to the point of the
night where we were eating desserts
and a lot of desserts including former
non-sponsor sponsors honey mamas yes
and non-sponsored dunkin donuts glazed
donut that i picked up i wish they were
a sponsor me too
so we were eating all these sweets and
indulging too much and then i thought oh
[ __ ] i gotta try
the pickle pop yeah bob's pickle pops
and
it was just the wrong time to try it for
the first time because my mouth had was
you know accustomed to having sweets in
it and you don't want to have something
salty like that after the sweet so it
was jarring it was jarring it was it was
good but it was a little weird it was a
little too weird for me and i thought oh
[ __ ] now i have
all these pickle pops what am i going to
do with these things and i don't know if
they're for me
and what am i going to say to this guy
who was nice enough to send right i know
we were a little nervous uh so then cut
to cut you the next day
uh i got up and i thought ah let me try
having a pickle pop now also on the
package it says it says it's for infants
and sports and uh in for um i think it's
for infants and athletes athletes yeah
and we thought sports why would this be
good for sports
but you think and you had you pointed
out that your body um your body needs
sodium after it's we had just done yoga
and we had to sweat a lot out and yoga
with tim yeah another another sponsor
non-sponsor sponsor
and
i
felt a um
a need to have one of these
uh pickle pops also because it's like
part of it is is refreshing they're from
it is it is refreshing so i had one and
i
absolutely loved it
and throughout the course the day i had
three more so i had four i i became
instantly addicted to that oh you really
did a 180 i've yeah they're trying so
good and now i went from
uh feeling like i didn't know what to
say to this guy because i i wasn't crazy
about it you don't know when to stop now
i'm like
we have enough of them now now i'm
nervous that we'll run out of them isn't
that that's an amazing i can't remember
the last time i did a 180 like that on a
on a food item and then on top of it
last night i indulged again in a
uh sunset oh yeah gin martini you had a
great idea by the way there's a part of
me that thinks you shouldn't be talking
about this because you should patent
this it's a really good idea
i'm never gonna patent it okay
so i thought hi instead of olive juice
on the bottom of this glass maybe i'll
put a little bit of the
pickle juice bob's pickle juice bob's
pickle juice not an ad and i did and it
was delicious so there you go even if
you don't like and i tried it and i
loved it i'm not even a big martini man
so thank you bob's pickle pops yeah and
i recommend them to anybody who likes
pickles or pickle teenies pickletini
yeah so give it a shot uh and speaking
of delicious things to eat i last night
uh while still up in the cabin made a
what christian pointed out as being my
the worst meal i've ever prepared
it was i stand by that what uh well the
first thing that i did was our friend
james got us leaks these big
fat leaks um and i thought oh i i've
heard of grill you can grill leeks i got
a nice grill going
uh i'll just i'll just toss some on the
grill they look like two tomahawks
didn't they
yeah they did a very thick base
and um
i put some olive oil on it some salt but
that's it that's all i did to them and i
thought it wouldn't by the way it
wouldn't have mattered what you did to
them
you could have put the most delicious
seasoning on them it wouldn't have
mattered they were awful so okay you had
four items you made burgers
corn
grilled leeks and
fourth thing yes mushrooms that were
right portobellos that i made before and
i've i've never had a problem with but
these tasted they weren't totally cooked
all four things were different levels of
disgusting disgusting so you know what i
think we might do at the end of this
because i recorded you talking about the
leak and trying to eat the leak so i
might play some voice memo you recorded
that yeah
yeah i thought it was really funny
because you were fascinated by how
terrible it was but you're a really good
cook and you often make really good
meals yeah i wasn't offended i
acknowledged it was true every item of
that meal and the burger i think that
wasn't your fault either you got when
you get burnt when you get burger meat
that's really compressed you know in
those little pre-packaged like freezable
squares they're always kind of tough
it's never the right kind of meat to get
but here's the thing i've been trying i
want to eventually wean myself off meat
i'm trying to eat less meat so this
because the burger wasn't good it was
like it just uh highlighted the fact
that i was wasting an animal you know
yeah
that's how well maybe you should eat
shitty burgers in order to get yourself
i should to quit me because now i want
it less i have less of a desire for it
whereas a couple nights earlier our
friend james grilled delicious delicious
so the leaks were disgusting couldn't
chew through them the burgers were not
great no the corn was not in season it's
not your fault it wasn't in season and i
didn't cook it properly i was also i had
been
i smoked a little i was a little stoned
and i sometimes lose track of time
either time gets really slow or fast and
in this case it tastes like you cooked
them for eight seconds yeah i think it's
just boiling water i blanch them
and the last thing and the mushroom was
was wasn't great because it was old it
was an older mushroom so a lot of it was
really involved it wasn't your fault but
it still was the grossest yeah so maybe
i'll play a little snippet of uh and now
i want to learn how to cook leaks uh
okay now what we're doing is oh i told
dave closer to one it's now 153. he said
he was available between
one and two all right we gotta work six
here we go uh okay and we're gonna ask
him about our grandmother if she should
be leaving and um oh and he has a fun
zoom background that he just showed me
uh
which i've noticed people have been
using zoom backgrounds
like a friend hey dave
hey sorry it ended up being closer to
two as you can see sorry i should have
texted you we've been rambling on
well i didn't know that we're on eastern
time or central time here you know yeah
we uh vid time quarantine yeah yeah
every time is the right time yeah i
guess it's not really a quarantine
anymore i mean you know that though
right is it not oh so
we're overlapping
quarantine refers to you know people who
are exposed to an illness who we don't
know if they're sick so they're they
have to stay in you know inside
very early on we were quarantining
people for exposure but then once there
was community exposure there was no more
quarantine oh now we need a new name
yeah what do we call this podcast now
yeah i just ruined this whole podcast
lockdown uh lockdown chat uh stay at
home
yeah i don't know i like the car you
know we'll figure it out uh how how's
your quark are you so you're home now
dave
yeah i'm home today okay have you been
how often or have you been going in
it's variable um so we're you know we're
doing a lot of telehealth yeah but we're
still of course still staffing the er 24
7. okay
and and how's uh how's salah doing
um she's here with me
hi
hey
hey sayla how how are you have you guys
been finding plays to do
um well i'm doing this broadway camp
you're doing it great
that's exciting so do you do you will
you be doing a different play how does
that work do you know if you do a
different play every week or you just
work on scenes
well for the broadway cam it's just
going to be virtual and like we're going
to like learn about broadway stuff and
like and then where there's going to be
a play near the end oh that's exciting
so then you all put on a virtual play
yeah well say i i i heard your uh
british accent is really good
no that was that was adira that's the
youngest one oh that's adira
oh yeah
you're a british accent go ahead no i
didn't show you though
did like an impression of hermione you
know that that line over and over again
oh it was funny you know harry potter so
say
uh let's hear your british accent say uh
ask say daddy uh can i offer you can
would you fancy a spot of tea
[Music]
one two three go
you wanna do a different
you wanna do a different line maybe um
uh i i don't have to do what you say
yeah
you do that one hmm
i don't have to do what you say oh
that's pretty good that's pretty good
that's really good i think ran into it
yeah you really well you also had a lot
of motivation for that line that was a
good that line yeah i think that was the
perfect line
oh that'll be fun she looked right at me
when she said
really well we both gave her motivation
um
yes well well so that sucks so wow so
they're doing it virtually virtual camps
interesting
yeah
it will be interesting yeah
but fun so fun i mean and then you'll
get to see kids so say will your friends
be doing that with you
well one of my friends amaya he's going
to be doing it with me oh cool okay
great that's great that's exciting well
good i'm glad because i know you were
disappointed that
you know school you didn't get to do it
at school
yeah well this would be good
wow that's good
that's that's
i feel like that's pretty rare
um i don't know if it's rare we make too
much of a meme or whatever out of not
liking that's true i think well it's not
cool to like school yeah well that's
good and and has sales seen back to the
future
you know i
that's like my weekend mission is that
we haven't watched that right yet
oh
she's definitely old enough for when you
guys she was listening to you guys
talking about i'm like yes that is
i'm so excited is one out there i'm at
the oh yeah purchase it but no no one is
on um
it's on netflix it is yeah yeah it's on
netflix it's great oh yeah dave how are
you
i know i'm jealous of her and i'm
jealous of dave for getting to see it
with somebody for the first time that's
that that's one of our favorite things
though is going through like the old
movies together right and some silly
ones what did we do we didn't do
ghostbusters yet did we
oh
man parent trap parent
the one the original one or the lindsay
lohan one
which one would happen
oh
[Music]
oh these are classics yeah um your dad
just showed me his zoom background and
it won't it won't mean anything to you
now but uh i that back to the future is
my favorite movie and so i really i
really loved it because it's the inside
of their i don't want to give anything
away yes you can't give it anywhere yeah
um oh et is another one a while ago
yeah just these classics classics but
you know like each is a good example of
one uh this is something i missed too at
the hollywood bowl they show
uh
christians making fun of me i can't say
bowl bowl your your eyebrows spazz when
you're trying to try it with a british
accent bowl the hollywood bow oh you
could do that oh yeah
so i was taking in a concert at concert
what is that scottish
i was taking it in a concert under the
stars at the hollywood bowl bowl
and there was a beautiful they showed an
old movie there which is now old at the
time it was quite modern modern
anyway they showed jurassic park and um
and yeah i saw e.t recently and those
movies i just wonder how kids feel about
them because they seem to have held up
so well
uh where you know but from my
perspective but i wonder if kids see
that and they think ah these i don't
this looks old-fashioned you know
and i get the effects on what do you
think well for 18
i watched it a while ago like the first
time like
like
it wasn't that old yeah
when i first watched it it wasn't like
really old like it is now
is like you know honey i shrunk the kids
movies like these you know even the
comedies
um is the female roles are
very different oh
yeah
yeah you noticed that a lot right yeah
oh interesting yes they weren't as
probably
fleshed out and three-dimensional and
yeah maybe they were a little bit more
like
and they change with each decade and
it's interesting to track that you know
and see what happens well what i've
noticed on disney plus when they show a
movie that uh
is maybe more old-fashioned and has
culturally isn't as
sensitive or progressive they'll say
there'll be a warning on it and it'll
say may contain uh
potentially offensive cultural
depictions or something have you noticed
that
yeah yeah they'll say it for like you
know like pocahontas
um
i think pocahontas might be okay
oh you do yeah i think that's like a
strong female that's true character and
yeah i i think there might be other
there might be other problems i mean
once from like a little mermaid is
pretty offensive to mermaids that not
all mermaids
but you know what you know
at first yeah when sailor was younger
like i was you know i was scared to show
some of these things and then i i
learned that they just as long as you're
talking about them they stimulate such
great
such great discussions yeah that's
problematic you know
so that's good it's good to talk about
problems
we need to talk about problems well
speaking of problems
um our we have a problem we have a
personal problem which is our
grandmother who you know is 103. oh no
yeah she's like her upstart
friend young young and friend is taking
her to who's 95 is taking her out to
like she went to a restaurant the other
day
they she went and got her hair done
her nails
do you know hone in what's the problem
well just that we're afraid she's
potentially well here's the bigger
picture you know i'm probably going to
take grandma's side but you know well i
hope you do here's the bigger problem
though dave she also our uncle wants to
he's going to is planning on driving
down there helping her pack up her stuff
because we want her up north or we did
before all this happened um and and now
we're afraid of her being exposed to
this so he's going to go down there
he's going to pack her up and then drive
her back for over the course of three
days in hotels along the way and yeah so
we wanted to know how you felt about
that and maybe other listeners are in a
similar position with loved ones where
they're gonna be safer to take a plane
yeah
i mean in part right is it
is it about covid or is it not about
covid because um
there was a really good article
i'll start with this like a friend of
mine i'm getting a lot of these
questions lately and you know very well
read smart people are having trouble
figuring out how to assess their own
risk in this whole thing and my friend
was literally like i sent him an article
he's like ugh i couldn't even find that
on google like it's so hard to find good
information
and uh this was just a times article but
it was just talking about a concept
called micro mortz which was new to me
have you heard that
it's uh
micro more micro more is saying um
you're you know you have a one in a
million chance of something so it's hard
for us to understand million or billion
or big numbers but um but you could
understand one micro mort right
or yeah so so so let's say you have a
one in a million chance of
um
you know dying for some something so
like for example uh skydiving you know
skydiving has a has a seven micro more
you know or you know yeah you know every
jump during the covid peak just being a
new yorker made you a 50. wow wow and
and uh and childbirth can you guess what
that is
um
i would guess at 12
210
210
210. so when you put risks in
perspective oh my god you realize that
you know look you could look around what
did sayla say
2 210 210 what of the risk of childbirth
wow i'm talking about mike remorts she
started you started multitasking oh
we'll talk about later she's very good
at math um she's fact checking me i
might get some new numbers um look
there's over five million cases
worldwide right now covid and the deaths
are over 350 000. um america you know uh
has you know greater the third of those
you know of course we just surpassed the
hundred thousand mark index and we have
over 1.5 million but but you know i
could go on and on about these stats for
every disease you know medically yeah
exists for every risk every time you
smoke a cigarette you're increasing some
micro mort right and so i think when it
comes we talked about this a little last
time but when it comes to now making
decisions related to covet you need to
start putting them it's very personal
you need to put them into perspective
i went into pediatrics in part because
adults don't listen
anyway so i don't know if it matters
what i say but but you know if it really
is just coming down assessing your risk
for things everything is relative right
and there is a risk to staying indoors
um and not socializing and um
and there is something to be said true
in your life but when it's not at the
expense of other people right that's the
big thing
yeah so so i think that you know that's
where reasonable risks come in you know
you and you go into the card you put
your seatbelt on and that's a choice
that you've now drastically lowered your
microphone so in terms of when you yeah
so well i had another question too
unrelated but i was just wondering why
you got into pediatrics
oh no i'm kidding
no i'm kidding i i
just wanted you to repeat because adults
don't listen um
yeah i just i've never i i will never
lose my passion for fighting and
advocating for children and children's
health and
you know they deserve they deserve all
of our energy to give you know whatever
it is medicine or anything else like um
they they deserve they deserve our
efforts to make their life better um and
i totally disagree but um you know to
each his own uh
but so in terms of like reducing her
micro mort uh the micro mort of her trip
i don't know if i've used that properly
but how how then if my grandmother is
going to
go back with my uncle if her son's going
to drive her back how can they best
minimize their micro more output
right so the first thing is he needs to
really
be uh
honest about his own risk what his
exposures have been in the 14 days prior
to going down there and he needs to have
a cancellation policy that may not fit
into previous choices we make in life
you know people show up to work with a
little sniffle or they say yeah tell
themselves oh maybe it's allergies you
know
and um you know we have a whole society
that does that functions based on an
acceptable threshold of getting each
other sick that's the norm that's been
the norm um i you know i'm not
advocating one way or another but
certainly if we wanted it to look
differently we'd have to make a lot of
changes yeah to to paid sick leave to
not linking insurance to employment
right to incentivizing people to stay
home when they're sick instead of the
opposite frankly and and uh so yeah he
has to not be sick okay
and then and he has to be okay canceling
it okay uh and then he goes down there
and then you know they should wear masks
and the biggest thing i'd worry about is
sort of of all the public stops along
the way so if they're driving over three
days you know see like she's also 103 so
she's going to have to go
to the bathroom and you know there's
going to be fairly regular it seems it's
crazy it does doesn't it yeah it seems
crazy it seems safer to fly doesn't it
but but but most people make mistakes
when they're not being vigilant so the
fact is that you're so freaked out by
that bathroom you're gonna you're gonna
have your handy wipes
you're gonna wipe it down the handle you
know all this stuff you'll go in there i
mean look like when i take my kids to
the bathroom and they're little like i
treated a place like it was an operating
room and i had to sterilize it you know
but but it's when you're it's when
you're somewhere else that you may not
be paying as close attention right and
your hand you know might might touch a
surface and you're just not thinking
that's something i need to worry about
it goes to your face yeah exactly
so really that's right trust they'll be
vigilant i do you do i think they'll be
very vigilant well so honestly and and
the risk the risks of a long trip like
that are not just covered right so for
someone her age traveling that long you
worry about blood clots forming you know
i know it's it doesn't so even in that
sense too it seems much better for her
to be flying now
but then do you have to worry about the
recycled air i know we've talked about
this my mother was worried about the
like
she had this thing about the air blowing
on her and what if it's
what if someone on god forbid someone on
that plane is sick because
then then she's stuck in this
yeah it i guess it gets down to this
like things that are feeling more in
control of your risk versus out of
control and this has always been the
thing about flying like we know that
statistically speaking your micro mort
from dying in a car is much higher than
yeah i know
that never changes how i feel about
being in a plane it's just a loss of
control so it's that loss of control yes
you know um so realistically yeah like
plane travel in general from an accident
perspective is safer from a covid
perspective again i think there's such
heightened vigilance right now to it
that um and one thing the flights did
when you think about incentivizing um
you know good behavior is the
cancellation uh policies change so that
you know previously
you know you needed like to show that
you were at a funeral right with a note
from a doctor that someone died to get
out of a flight right um unless you paid
for cancellation insurance all that
stuff so now there's sort of there's
this like okay look if you have a runny
nose just don't come don't worry about
it yeah
well but so yeah i i don't know i mean
there's i think people have to what i
really want to express is people need to
make the choices that are best for them
and their families and that are also
keeping them psychologically safe so
so it's not for nothing that if you feel
safe for driving
um then for that anxiety piece like
that's that means something if it was
like out of proportion more risk and
it's just in your head then then that's
different you know but so dave and you
got it you got to factor that in but
what about for us what about what if we
were to fly down what the dangers of
flying now like how would you compare
that to
driving i mean you're not dealing with
touching as many things obviously
surfaces stops but what about what about
that the recycled air in the plane uh
this is a very selfish question but i
know i'm sure a lot of people are going
to be wanting to fly and see loved ones
i know a friend of mine her birthday's
coming up wants to
go to see her family so how do people
contend with air travel now right right
i honestly don't know because um
it's just hard it's hard i mean there
was like make something up
yeah so
i will say that um remember for this
particular virus it's spreading via
droplets so right um it's not like going
to float in the air to you if someone in
row and two rows behind you sneezes and
they're not wearing a mask and it flies
and yeah then you're then it's in your
space yeah um
so so wear a mask
glasses wearing a mask if everyone's
wearing masks which they are now i'm
more worried like down a few weeks down
the line when people relax because yeah
nothing's changed you know nothing
you know it's not the virus is not going
to change how it's spread so in a few
weeks i'm tired of wearing this mask you
know or if there are people on your
plane who already have that attitude
that's where we have a problem you know
um there are already countries where the
culture has routinely been to wear a
mask and yeah some of them are places
where they've experienced scourges like
this with previous sars viruses that
never reached our shores then we were
always you know uh looking at that like
hey what's with the masks you know and
now we understand that it's just a
general politeness that that some
societies have consideration uh
consideration when you're in public that
it eases other people's minds that
you're not gonna spread something to
them well it's i've been noticing that
it has that effect on me i mean i love
you know i love that this has become
i don't love that it's become the norm
but it's it's
obviously very comforting that it's
become the mask part has become the norm
um dave sorry we we uh i we rambled too
much and you you were uh thank you i we
gotta go but uh i i really appreciate it
i gotta go too um well we gotta go too
no no i gotta go okay well we have to go
first
no really i'm totally going now yeah um
all right thanks buddy and thanks
thanks ayla see you offline about
grandma let's make sure we're safe thank
you we appreciate it as always all right
thanks soon take care bye life could be
a dream sweetheart
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vied for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
christmas tis the season to deck the
halls and exchange presents with loved
ones but over the past decade a new
tradition has emerged binge watching low
budget made for tv holiday movies the
all-new podcast series business wars
christmas movie wars looks at how
christmas films started creating massive
profits and how the battle to have the
highest rated christmas movies has
become an intense christmas tradition in
2009 the hallmark channel aired
wall-to-wall holiday programming from
thanksgiving to christmas surprisingly
it was a ratings bonanza and rocketed
the little watch channel to number one
hallmark's competitor lifetime took note
and launched their own block of
christmas movies this sparked a rivalry
that has lasted almost a decade and then
netflix started making christmas movies
and what started as a business
competition turned into an all-out
battle for viewers attention listen to
business wars christmas movie wars on
amazon music apple podcast or you can
listen early and add free by joining
wondering plus in the wondery app
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
now i'm gonna be seeing life through
micro morts
i know everything i do now it's such a
fun word to say it is how many micro
morts are uh in this situation sounds
like a harry potter term now that even
though i've never read it uh i i'm
hearing harry potter terms all the time
our friend we've mentioned dan we've
been doing this trivia every tuesday dan
schechter uh great director
double plug after class um dan does the
trivia and one of the questions was
really great question it said uh of
these three
there were three lists of names and and
it said which category is a list is it
are names of um
uh harry potter characters and and which
uh other two are the names am i but you
really butcher this basically it was a
way to tell the difference between harry
potter names in the harry potter world
yeah and names of drugs yes that's what
it was and the the thing is that they're
very similar very similar in one
category i just remember we got we got
it right only because i remembered oh
i'm sorry it wasn't harry potter it was
lord of the ring it was chair totally oh
you're right it was lord of the rings
characters and one was i mean similar
worlds yeah right or if i think
or if oh or the potter heads are gonna
have something to say about and the
talking heads yeah the token heads might
be scarier because token heads have been
around longer older
yeah and that and a lot of them maybe
have become game of thrones heads that's
a good that's a good would you rather
would you rather piss off a token head
or a piss off a potter head
i would rather piss off a potter head i
would too less threatening i would say
they're gonna be mad at that i know and
the tokenizers are gonna be like yeah
that's right
we'll smite you with our orcsaber
um okay that thanks dave as always and
sayla that's exciting she's doing that
was sweet it was sweet to hear her
excited you know
but what is that going to be like a zoom
i didn't want to say it obviously i'm on
the i'm with her but like doesn't that
seem
difficult to be fun yeah but
you get used to it it's just a new way
of communicating and it's it's a new
reality i think that sounds easier to do
than um like tanglewood doing an online
concert series
yeah kids getting together and doing
instructional
yeah i shouldn't i'm not [ __ ] on it
i'm just like wondering how it's going
to work uh wait speaking of it really
quick we should mention the uh
the thing we did the celebrity watch
party
oh
yeah but i don't think we um a little
funny addendum to that if you've been
listening to the quarantine episodes is
uh so christian and i watched a clip we
were on the show where we watched little
clips of things [ __ ] certain shows and
uh they filmed us
reacting to it and there was one
we talked about it last week when
christian watched ben platt's
performance
um with his brothers his equally like
angelic sounding brothers and he got a
christian god
emotional he got obviously emotional and
um but a little funny adventure to that
is they used me getting emotional yes
thankfully very brief briefly yeah so
they cut from like little romeo and and
master p being like what's this he's not
little romeo romeo he's middle-aged
romeo they caught all of the i was
talking about how he's oh we talked
about that for about an hour
about middle-aged romeo yeah a lot of
little jokes um
how romeo and and formerly little mr
master p and now just masterpiece master
pettington
they they cut from them to you like
wiping your eyes and stuff but here's
the the funniest part is they didn't
even use i guess they couldn't get maybe
the rights to the ben platt performance
or they for whatever reason they didn't
use the ben platform i think they had
the rights i'm sure they had the right
but they used they used a different and
it was thing it was just kids singing
singing the the national anthem which is
very sweet sweet and moving but but
didn't move me
[Music]
but as far as everyone who saw that and
a lot of people saw it because i was
getting texts from like people that
normally wouldn't text me uh hey i saw
you on this thing um so people did watch
it and and oh good that that really that
is comfort as far as as far as their i
didn't get any text by that oh you
didn't well i also have a mustache and
thick glasses on
you didn't get recognized uh anyway i
thought that was funny um but for the
record he was if you saw it and you
listened for the few people who saw that
and listened to the show in the venn
diagram yeah like three people it was
fun to do i would i would do that show
again oh yeah um okay okay let's do a
couple would you rather before we have
to go okay okay um first one is from
hannah because we have to do an
interview i have to do an interview
later and i'm not going to say who it is
oh spoil the surprise growth yep
it's a good one though oh yeah it is a
good one yeah now you want to say
okay the first one hannah from hannah p
subject would you rather hi justin
christian i've been trying for weeks to
come up with a good would you rather
this is my imagination or do we get a
lot of hannah letters
or am i just more sensitive to that name
i have an awareness of that name i don't
know i can't answer that debut i feel
like we have two a lot of hannah's what
if he's the same person writing it over
and over
um oh another good letter from another
hannah i've been trying for weeks to
come up with a good would you rather
descend in so far this is the only one i
have
would you rather have permanently sticky
skin or permanently slimy skin
kind of lame but that's all i got i
wanted and i want to be involved thanks
for reading and stay healthy it's hannah
p but first of all hannah you are you
should not be doubting yourself i think
it's lame that's a good one it's a
really good one i've got an easy answer
okay but it's still a good one slimy
skin or sticky skin
i mean how sticky how slimy so sticky
that you when you bump into stuff you're
stuck to it so slimy that you leave a
residue when you touch things like a
frog like a slug would
you almost said frog and you didn't want
to insult me alex also i uh some frog's
skin is well
toads are not slimy this is a slippery
slope yeah i know slimy slow pun
intended slippery slimy slope um
oh man that's a good one or is it like a
slimer from ghostbusters kind of slimy
that would be you
i'd rather like you'd be slipping and
sliding all over the place slimy well
hold on i just thought of a sexual
element which is like
the surprise it took you so long it did
that's sad that it took me this long
because i was thinking about practical
things you know like touching papers or
touching just greeting people not that
you do that anymore hugging someone or
with kids uh i would i would say holding
hands right i would say in general it's
it's
the extreme of either is awful but
in general i when i get
something sticky on my hands
versus getting something slippery on my
hands like oil versus um
a tacky tar
sap that's what i i'm remembering i
remember i am more bothered by the
sticky one yeah so i would rather be
slippery
yeah attack something like tacky i don't
like the feeling of
that on my fingers sticking together
but that's a good one that is a really
good one all right uh let's do another
one uh this is from tyler f would you
rather hey justin christian the most
underrated movie to watch during the
quarantine is drag me to hell a timely
morality tale of what could happen if
you for close on a gypsy woman during a
recession that said that's true would
you rather spend your life kicking
people out of their homes or spend an
eternity in hell
tyler from ontario canada ps probably
too dark and political for your podcast
but i'm a big fan and wanted to ask
uh that's a good one it is uh that's
tough so okay so this is assuming
there's an afterlife
right this is assuming there's a hell
and my
vision of hell is so awful i'd rather i
mean i hate to say this i know well this
exposes a selfish element of me that i
would rather
but you know what i would do i would
choose the kicking people out of their
homes but then i would find a way to
make it up to them to make it up to them
so they don't put a curse on you
or just to help you yes i wouldn't want
to hurt them yeah
yeah i would because it's all you both
have to want to help people that you've
kicked out of their home if the question
was would you rather spend your life
murdering people
or being held that's different it's
different because for like kicking
people out of their homes is it's an
awful thing to do obviously but there's
a way there's a way for them to recover
first of all and there's a way for you
to make it up to them and there's a way
to argue that as gross as it is i mean
it's not like you own the foreclosure
company or the mortgage company that's
responsible maybe tyler would say you do
like you're responsible like okay
bernie madoff who did
awful good things like ruin people's
lives yeah so if i had that money and
that power that that type of money
affords you then yeah i would do what
you suggested which is i would try to
balance it out with them i would i would
suggest to make this a fair hypothetical
you you shouldn't
yeah probably because
then it just becomes but then
how how much do you value your own life
versus the lives of others and afterlife
and well right yeah versus the lives of
others i mean it really exposes your
selfishness this question it does but in
a weird way yeah i know but an eternity
that's tough
um all right all right let's do another
one okay this is from julie r
subject my first email to a podcast
that's cool yeah hey fellas i mean i
don't know julie so it's it's not like
it's a little bit like well uh
who cares well so flattering that's the
i think it's cool it's good for both of
us yes first the obligatory and 100
sincere love the show
it's definitely nice it's not obligatory
you don't have to say that but thank you
for saying that tyler didn't say no
you're under no obligation to say you
love the [ __ ] i listen every week and
find myself legitimately laughing out
loud regularly you guys seem to have a
really great relationship and it's super
fun to hear that's not obligatory either
no second i hate to be that guy but on
the last quarantine episode there were
several references to
lacroix or the quoi did we say wrong
spark uh sparking beverages she meant
sparkling beverages which are delicious
and refreshing but it's pronounced
lacroix well she's shaming right now
that's true that's true wait i think i
say lacroix i think you might say
lacroix but maybe you said lacroix
really this is like the iroquois or aqua
thing that we went well okay wait she
says it's lacroix she goes on to say
uh it's pronounced lacroix according to
the lacroix website
frequently asked questions
it quote it rhymes with enjoy quote
quote it rhymes with enjoy so look
it rhymes with enjoy
that's funny lacroix enjoy liquid rhymes
within hoy
[Laughter]
in high well can you say
likoy lecoy lacroix i think it's lacroix
yeah la coy rhymes with enjoy but no one
says lakota here's the problem with that
the oi part the end part
is friend it's got an x at the end so
that's a french pronunciation i know but
i so shouldn't quoi also be it shouldn't
it also be put out the first part of the
word be pronounced french the french way
too
lacroix why would you say you don't say
uh
chris chris croissant crossover you say
well i think that's a little pretentious
to over you know that's french but it's
cross saw
yeah i know i know but but why say a
pretentious why say one part of the word
why not say la croix
what are you one part of the word
no oy the the x the the um silent x
lacroix
you're saying
lacroix
i think when you
say it in english it's lacroix
oh i guess so x in english is also
silent right
lacroix i don't know like well according
to that i just have to take the right
sioux falls
yeah you don't say sioux city you don't
say
su
right but they're not saying you should
say the lacrosse actress it's not the
croix
right i know lacroix all right sioux
falls that's how soups falls
yeah i'm trying to think that's the crux
of the matter that's different
the fox and the hounds yeah not all x
words need to be pronounced that's true
how do you okay but i get and i guess i
would say well how who's to say lacroix
lacroix is exactly they've got to do it
yeah so this is all moot all of our i
may be wrong but i thought i always say
lacroix
did i say lacroix maybe i did lacroix i
think of it more as lacroix than lacroix
i think i remember you saying liquid we
can listen no okay okay um well it's
good to know
third here is a would you rather would
you rather have century egg flavored ice
cream as your only dessert option ever
century egg flavor like it's been an egg
that's been sitting around for a century
i don't know what that is maybe that's
what it is century egg flavored ice
cream as your only dessert option ever
or
fully intact dehydrated tarantulas
as your only pizza topping option ever
i'm not sure if google images
um i'm not sure if googling images of
each of each option helps or hurts the
decision vomit emoji thanks again for
making your thoroughly enjoyable podcast
i love julie r from pennsylvania thank
you julie that is really sweet um that's
that's not an obligatory thank you i
would say maybe it is
say
i i i hear more about i i deserve more i
i was gonna yeah you know
so i would i take the ice cream well i
see i think
by that logic you have to take the pizza
the tarantulas on the pizza
pizza exactly i just wouldn't eat pizza
right right and it'd be good yeah i
don't know century it'd be hard not to
have pizza ice cream is but it sounds
gross and not you could get used to if
that was my only ice cream option that's
a different question but if it's my only
dessert option right i i have to open
myself up tomorrow all right let's say
your pizza is not important let's say
it's your only ice cream option you just
give up ice cream uh i should anyway i
kind of want yeah
yeah i think i would give up ice cream
and i think i could do that the dry also
the dried tarantulas
it might not be once you got over the
psychological grossness dehydrating of
eating spiders
yeah it might the taste itself might not
be bad no i would say if it weren't
tarantula here's to me the grossest
people they're hairy hairy but if
they're dehydrated wouldn't be hairy
they would be yeah yeah and they're
quite hairy i mean it's not like that'd
be tough yeah if they were a little like
i don't know house spiders or brown
recluse spider whatever would that be
poisonous
um
i can't think of other spiders
um all right let's do a one more and
it's a letter
it is a letter that's a good one j i
that is an interesting one last one is
from
katie
w
hi justin and christian my name is katie
and i write to you from coastal south
jersey
i'm a flower farmer and love to listen
to your podcast while i'm working in my
field that's cool this quarantine came
at a real crazy time for me and my
family we are in the middle of upgrading
our farm from an acre to 20 acres all in
this craziness i do not recommend buying
and selling a home in the middle of a
pandemic oh my god this summer's farmers
market season is all up in the air for
me and my fellow market members i hope
to have some form of it soon but who
knows because of that i have a business
for you to feature great a fellow vendor
and good friend hand makes the best
headbands you can get and i've noticed
your quarantine coifs could use some
managing
funny we're just talking about that your
coif could definitely do some managing
yeah so it's rey's headband company and
rey spelt r-a-e-r-a-e
and the website is
www.raiseheadbandco.com
that's
raise
headband co
dot com huh it looks cool i'm looking at
it now thank you for all you two do to
keep all of our eye full and brains
stimulated
uh this raised headband thing this is
exactly what i need i've been looking
for i've been using
maggie your girlfriend's little headband
um which i don't mind doing but it keeps
falling off and these are this is
exactly what i need this is kind of like
a uh
how would you describe this
headband oh i could see you in that loop
yeah it's almost like um
see like serene like a tennis player
yeah yeah that keeps
um really ext
big hair back like like dreadlocks like
um yeah i've seen rafael nadal wear that
yeah i mean
not to compare myself you're a little
bit like the much less athletic version
of rafael nadal you have some nadal
vibes too yeah you know a little bit
like um there was a movie that wes study
studi the great actor um pl native
american actor uh
starred in geronimo you played john you
remember that movie geronimo
he wore a headband kind of like that
yes yeah that's cool rey's headband co
okay okay cool and would you rather to
finish it all off oh nice would you
rather
be only a would you rather i thought she
was gonna say the name of her floral
company i do too yeah and also i wanted
to look up that's what i was i've been
meaning to talk about that because james
and gemma recommended uh that far
there's a farmer's market somebody else
did too
that you can go there's a website you
can find your local farmers uh who are
selling their wares who are obviously
not doing it now at farmers markets you
can find it um
where they are how they're they're
delivering them now
do you remember the name of that i don't
i don't i wasn't part of that
conversation oh okay uh so finally yeah
let's wrap this up
with uh would you rather to only be able
to eat vegetables or fruit for the rest
of your life
one or the other not not everyone okay
oh one or the other yeah oh that's a
good one that is a good one
uh vegetables are fruit
that's tough i love them i'm assuming
it's this is not including like using
in cooking and cooking and vegetable
juice in products and fruit juices you
got to include it really
um that's tough how about let's just say
for these on their own just vegetables
or fruit okay cooked or raw okay
and not juice excuse me i just burped a
little bit which i did too i burst at
the same time oh wow so you think you're
we were talking about which that's a
good would you rather you're talking
about would you rather be able to
conceal your
uh would you rather be able to burp
freely in front of people or fart
well you know i was just thinking this
round of would you rather on this
episode it was
relatively um
yeah sort of fart free and it's just as
i had that thought you brought
hypothetical into the mix well we were
talking about it because james's uh
wonderful wife uh
hates burps perfect she hates them way
more than she hates farts and she's one
of the most tolerant easygoing people
i've ever met in my life and been around
and she uh does not
tolerate but
as far as eigen does the only thing she
doesn't tolerate is burps um and i never
met anyone like that who who prefers
tolerates burps less than farts
uh it's a really this is really tough
for me it's tough yeah i am my instinct
is to say vegetables me too uh they
you know i think i
eat more of them i enjoy
the taste and fruit with all the think
about dessert wise think about
it's really hard and think about going
to
you know a more like equatorial country
is that the right word uh near the
equator the more tropical country
like central america should i don't know
i got a fruit there yeah or a fresh
strawberry the ones that we have
strawberries up in massachusetts that's
just wild strawberries and
you pick one of those [ __ ] i pick one of
those suckers off them i'm gonna have to
uh ruminate on this one but my
i think if i got to my head right now i
i would pick fruit oh really actually
vegetables like let's think about it for
the next week okay and consider when you
have a fruit or a vegetable how much
you're interested all right all right
let's revisit this okay drink quarantine
episode 11. who was that a very oh much
more special next week
well already i feel like next week is
more special yeah uh who was that that
was this was kdw
ah
oh
i had an ex-girlfriend kdw
but i
don't believe it's the same one no i
don't think so unless you started a farm
really quick in the last uh i wish we
knew the name of kdw's farm i would love
to talk about it well kdw you should
write back in yeah
oh no i see your whole name now it's not
the same one okay
okay all right um all right well that's
the show yeah thanks for listening
everyone thanks to dr dave as always and
thank you for yeah thanks for all
the um people who wrote in hannah julie
tyler oh good memory i'm good at
remembering if you guys want to write in
to give us some would you rather's or to
just write a letter about anything you
want or to recommend a business a small
business your own or someone else's our
email address is life is short at
wondery.com
justin is looking off the distance and
mouthing something oh i to himself i was
i don't know why are you trying to
remember something yeah i was trying to
remember uh you know i was going to see
if people could recommend a local farm
but then i thought
that was you want to see what it looked
like
it's really weird i was also i think you
know the way inexperienced actors mouth
lines that they're not saying that they
know i think maybe i was mouthing the
light for sure the wondering oh weird
yeah well katherine o'hara and waiting
for gov there's a great scene waiting
for government where catherine o'er fred
willard we keep thinking about him maybe
that's why it's in my head uh
where he where they're doing a scene
they're auditioning with the scene and
katherine o'hara it's so funny that
katherine and i are a mao this when it's
not her line she mounts fred willard's
lines
brilliant a little touch uh anyway sorry
for doing that and for derailing this
great ending it was a great wrap-up i
was trying to make it great really good
you want to get back on there yeah too
late now well thanks for listening okay
uh remember next week is more special
that's true and we'll see on tuesday yes
for
i won't say it we're gonna keep it a
good great surprise all right here we go
thank you
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life for short is hosted by me justin
long and it's produced by you christian
long it's also produced by her pointing
to la megan monaco and senior producers
michelle miesh lans audio engineer is
sergio enriquez executive bruisers are
marshall louis and hernan lopez for uh
for
i wonder the
wondering
[Music]
you